thank you mr speaker this morning i had
meetings with ministerial colleagues and
others thank you amy thank you very much
immediately following pmq's i will
attend i will attend the welcome home
marching to thank all those involved in
op-pitting our evacuation from kabul in
addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
chris
i too will be attending and if
i too will be attending in a few minutes
nikki's seven-year-old son had 37
seizures a day because of a brain
disease he suffered from he's had
surgery now but it's a struggle every
day to get him to stay in school
and
she nikki is supporting the acquired
brain injury bill because she believes
that the government needs to have a
cross-departmental
strategy for supporting those who
haven't had an acquired brain injury
whether that's rugby players with
concussion and dementia
it's women who've been beaten in the
head by their partners um it's people
who've had brain injuries uh the judas
children who've had
suffered from carbon monoxide poisoning
soldiers who've been in explosions i
really hope that the government is going
to back the acquired brain injury bill
but above all we need a strategy to help
the 1.4 million people in this country
will he give us that prime minister
i want to thank the the right honourable
member for
raising this
vital issue for his commitment to this
to this cause his personal commitment
and i can assure him that uh we are
studying his uh proposed bill and uh
working to ensure that people
do get the support for the acquired
brain injuries that they uh have
received and what we can certainly
pledge at this stage to do and i hope
this will be of some uh use to him and
the many who care about this issue in
the way that he does and as i'm sure
members do across the house uh the
department of health and social care
will lead on the development of a cross
cross-departmental
government strategy on acquired brain
injury and other neurological uh
conditions i'll be uh very happy to
share details with him shortly
thank you mr speaker in july of this
year my constituency kensington suffered
devastating flooding with more than 2
000 homes flooded a river running down
portobello road and a lot of residents
having to move into temporary
accommodation
does my right honourable friend agree
with me that tham's water needs to come
up with short and long-term solutions
and they need to make sufficient
investment in infrastructure to prevent
events like this happening again
prime minister my older friend is
absolute rise to raise flooding mr
speaker and she's right about short and
long-term solutions and that's why i'm
proud amongst other things to have
helped him to instigate the thames
tideway tunnel uh with the biggest
supersewer in the in the history of this
country which will help to deal with
what happens uh in london when the basal
jet interceptors overflow and to deal
with flooding throughout the city leader
of the opposition kirstama
thank you mr speaker at the last
election the prime minister promised
that nobody would have to sell their
home to pay for care that's another
broken promise isn't it
prime minister
no
no mr speaker no mr speaker
because because if he looked at what we
are proposing and if he supported what
we are proposing which is fixing
something that a labor never fixed in
all their years in office mr speaker we
are saying to the people of this country
that we will disregard your home as part
of your assets if you and your spouse
live here and number two mr speaker
you can have a deferred payment
agreement if you if you move out of it
and you're living in in residential care
you can have a deferred payment but most
important of all mr speaker by putting
the huge investment that we are making
now in health and social care and we are
allowing for the first time the people
of this country to insure themselves
against the potentially catastrophic the
otherwise catastrophic costs of dementia
or alzheimer's mr speaker and
and even if you're not one of the those
people who suffer from those afflictions
we are taking away the anxiety from
millions of people millions of people up
and down the land about their homes
i think the prime minister just
described the broken system he said he
was fixing
so it's certainly not a straight answer
let's have another go
let's have another go
he used to say he used to say
he used i see that turned up this week
prime minister
mr speaker
mr speaker
he used to say he used to say that sorry
i don't think i need any further
yesterday we had a very good example of
the house being at its best in that
church in that cathedral please let's
show some respect i want to be able to
hear not only the prime minister but the
leader of the opposition shouting each
other down doesn't do you or your
constituents any good we need to hear
the questions and i certainly need to
hear the answers and if anybody doesn't
like it please leave now yes
[Applause]
mr speaker it's not a complicated
question so let's have another go he
used to say that nobody would have to
sell their home to pay for their care
it's in his manifesto right here
on the basis of that promise he then put
up tax on every working person in the
country so has he done what he promised
and ensured that nobody will have to
sell their home to pay for care yes or
no it's not complicated prime minister
no no it's not complicated mr speaker uh
because we're not because what we're
doing
is disregarding your home as part of the
assets uh that we calculate so if you go
down uh to a hundred thousand pounds uh
that's the that's the beginning uh where
we will ask you to to contribute but
your home is not included in that uh mr
speaker and they have they have
absolutely no plan they've spent decades
uh failing to address this and only if
only a few weeks ago mr speaker they
failed to they failed to vote for the 36
billion pounds that will enable us uh to
fix this and to help people up and down
the country uh not just to not just to
fix the social care from but to pay for
people to live in their own homes mr
speaker and receive the care they need
in their homes that's what this one
nation conservative government is doing
why won't he support it
mr speaker has had two opportunities to
stand by his manifesto commitment he's
not taking them
well it says he just has so so let's
test this in the real world prime
minister
under the prime minister's plans of
persons with a person with assets worth
about a hundred thousand pounds most of
it turned up in their home would have to
pay 80 000 pounds
they'd lose almost everything
how on earth how on earth does the prime
minister think that they can get their
hands on that kind of money without
selling their home
mr speaker i'm going to gather third
truck go trying to uh clear this up in
the in the befuddled mind of the right
honourable gentleman opposite okay and
it because it is it is important and the
fact is that the party opposite have
totally failed to address it they
haven't had the guts to fix this in all
their time in office it's something left
over it's something left over uh from
from the atlea government and we are
fixing it and
let me repeat let me repeat for the
third time mr speaker
your home is disregarded number two uh
even if you have even if you have a
secondhand view in your residential care
mr speaker you have a deferred payments
agreement if you want a number three mr
speaker we are allowing you to insure
yourself for the first time against the
catastrophic conflict by tapping it at
eighty six thousand mr speaker and now
he stood on a manifesto to put the cap
where mr speaker at a hundred thousand
pounds mr speaker
dear stammer
the the question was very simple it's
it's the question all of his back bench
not if you've got a house worth about
120 140 000 pounds how do you find 80
plus thousand pounds without selling
your home it's common sense
strip away the bluster strip away the
deflection strip away the refusal to
answer the question there's a simple
truth and this is why the prime minister
won't address it people will still be
forced to sell their homes to pay for
care that accounts
why did they
look at the vote the other day to see
the answer to that question
they'll still be forced to sell their
it's another broken promise just like
just like he promised that he wouldn't
put up tax
just like he promised 40 new hospitals
just like he promised a rail revolution
in the north
mr speaker
mr speaker
who knows who knows if he'll make it to
the next election
but if he does
how does he expect anyone to take him on
his promises seriously
prime minister mr speaker yet again he
raises the rail revolution in in the
north and uh
the three new high-speed lines mr
speaker 96 96 96 billion
nothing like it again nothing like it
nothing like it
nothing like it mr speaker nothing like
it for a century and and and just just
for the advantage of what i didn't i
didn't even know this i was in a state
of complete innocence about this last
week mr speaker but it turns out that
the right honorable gentleman actually
campaigned against hs2 altogether
i said it would be devastating and said
it should be cancelled i can tell you
something this is because hs2 runs
through my constituency as well and i
took a decision even though it's been
very tough for my constituents i took it
i could have took a decision that it was
in the right it was the right thing to
do for the long-term interest of the
whole country how can they possibly
trust that man
mr mr speaker i think he's lost his
place in his notes again
yeah
the only
[Applause]
the only thing
the only thing he's delivering is high
taxes high prices and low growth
i'm not sure the prime minister should
be shouting about that
and it isn't just broken promises it's
also about fairness
everyone needs protection against
massive health and care costs
but under his plans someone with assets
worth about a hundred thousand pounds
will lose almost everything yet somebody
with assets of about a million pounds
will keep almost everything
it's just like
it's just like their 2017 manifesto all
over again
only this time
something has changed
he's picked the pockets of working
people to protect the estates of the
wealthiest
how could he possibly have managed to
devise a working-class dementia tax
uh mr speaker
i think i've answered that question
three times
already this is this this does more this
does more for working people up and down
the country than labor ever did
and the neighbor ever did and because
we're actually solving the problem that
they failed for us we're disregarding
your housing asset altogether mr speaker
while you're in it and he talks about
jobs he talks about working people well
well let me let me just remind him
because one key statistic that people
should should bear in mind uh it's now
almost a month after furlough ended and
he talks about the the economy mr
speaker there are now more people in
work than there were before the pandemic
began and that's because of the policies
this government has pursued
mr speaker there's no getting away from
it working people are being asked to pay
twice during their working lives they'll
pay much more tax in national insurance
whilst those living off wealth are
protected and then when they retire mr
speaker they face having to sell their
home when the wealthiest won't have to
do so
it's a classic con game
a covent garden pickpocketing operation
the prime minister's the front man
distracting people with wild promises
and panto speeches
whilst his chancellor dips his hand in
their pocket
but now
but now the prime minister's routine is
falling flat
his chancellor is worried that people
are getting wise
his backbenchers say it's embarrassing
your words
[Music]
the word
your words
and
senior people in downing street tell the
bbc
it's just not working
is everything okay prime minister
right minister
well mr speaker i i tell you what's not
working it's that line of attack uh
i just i just i just want to i just want
to repeat i will i will i will want to
repeat the the crucial point uh mr
speaker we're delivering for the working
people of this country for the people of
this country and we're fixing the
problems that they thought could never
be fixed by doing the things that they
thought were impossible and let me
repeat there are now more people more
people in work in this country jobs up
with their wages going up mr speaker
than there were before the pandemic
began and that is because of the
policies that this government has
followed uh whether it's on rolling out
the vaccine if you remember uh that he
opposed uh whether it's on investment uh
they're here but he did mr thief he did
he didn't want to invest in the in the
vaccine task force i seem to remember i
said where all weather or whether or
whether it is making the strategic
investments that we have
if we listened if we listened to captain
hindsight mr speaker we would have no
hs2 at all because that was what he
stood for and if we listen to him we
would all still be in lockdown
[Applause]
speaker can the prime minister confirm
that he will use the rest of the uk's
presidency of cop to urge countries
around the world to make good on the
pledges that they made in glasgow and
does he agree with me that
decarbonization can create millions of
jobs across the uk and around the world
prime minister i i totally agree with my
right honourable friend who's right
about this and many other things and
that's why our transition to to green
jobs is is supporting 440 000 uh new
green high-wage high school jobs across
the the uk
and uh the breakthrough agenda that we
had endorsed at cop26 i believe will
support between 20 and 30 million jobs
across the world by 2030 and i think
that's probably a gross underestimate we
now come to the leader of the smp ian
blackford
thank you mr speaker i'm sure you will
wish to join me and indeed the rest of
the house and welcoming the moderator of
the church of scotland to the gallery
today
lord wallace and to thank him for his
sage words at his sermon this morning
mr speaker the past few weeks have shown
this tory government at its very worst
a tory sleaze and corruption scandal on
a scale not seen since the 1990s
tory cuts and tax rises that will leave
millions of people worse off
a litany of broken promises from hs2 to
carbon capture social care the triple
lock on pensions
and who can possibly forget the 20
billion pound bridge to ireland
evaporated
into thin air
at the center of all this
is one man
a prime minister who is floundering in
failure so can i ask the prime minister
with his party falling in the polls his
colleagues breathing against him
has he considered calling it a day
before he's pushed out the door
prime minister i you know mr speaker
what i i think what the people of this
country want to hear is less talk about
uh politics and politics and they want
to talk about what the government is
doing for the people of scotland
[Music]
and what and what the scottish
government is doing for the people of
scotland which isn't enough uh mr
speaker but what we will he talks about
uh infrastructure investment and i can
tell him that if he if he if he if he
will wait till uh i think until friday
or later this week he's going to hear
about what we're going to do with the
union connectivity review to ensure that
the people of scotland are served with
the connections that they need and which
the scottish nationalist party has
totally failed to put in
in blackfood
thank you mr speaker that certainly
wasn't an answer to the question i asked
but we're used to that and i didn't
expect the prime minister take
responsibility because he never does but
this
isn't just about the chaos in the
conservative party it's about the state
of the united kingdom under his failing
leadership because whilst the prime
minister spends his time hunting for
chatty pigs and staving off a leadership
challenge from the treasury in the real
world in the real world mr speaker
people are suffering a tory cost of
living crisis brexit is hitting the
economy hard but the prime minister
can't even give a coherent speech to
business the prime minister's officials
have lost confidence in him tony mps
have lost confidence in him the letters
are going in
and the public have lost confidence in
him
why is he clinging on when quite clearly
he simply isn't up to the job
speaker i might ask the the right
honourable gentleman what on earth uh he
thinks he is doing uh talking about uh
uh
party political issues when what the
people of scotland want to hear is what
on earth uh the scottish national
government is doing they're falling in
the polls uh mr speaker
their cause but yes they are their cause
is falling in the polls and considering
considering their manifold failures on
tax on education and all the things the
people of scotland really care about i'm
not surprised and i can see some
agreement on the benches opposite
the lord
mr speaker i i celebrate the recent
successes of woking college my local uh
sixth form college and i welcome the
recent government investment for a new
teaching block which will allow it to
expand
many colleges and students find
btex to be a really valuable
qualification and course
enabling progress into higher education
and skilled
employment
does the prime minister agree with me
that we should protect student choice
and keep btex
as an option for students
[Applause]
yes because we will continue i thank my
own we will continue to fund uh some
beat experts where there's a clear need
for them uh but i must stress to him uh
that we've got to close the gap between
uh the things that people study and the
needs of business and employers and
that's what t levels are designed to do
caroline luther
thank you very much uh mr speaker i
rarely agree with the prime minister but
last week when he said that cop 26
showed that we can end our reliance on
fossil fuels i did agree with him but
that begs the question as to why his
government is pressing ahead not just
with a combo oil field but with 39 other
oil gas and coal developments which
would amount to three times the uk's
current annual climate emissions now i
don't want an answer about all the
things he thinks he is doing on cars and
cash and trees i want him to tell the
house if he will leave those fossil
fuels in the ground will he cancel those
projects and does he recognize that if
he doesn't he will need to ask for
forgiveness not just for losing his
place in a speech but for losing the
future of our children
prime minister uh mr speaker we are not
only powering past coal going to uh
going to an end to
fossil fuel reliance in our uh our
energy generation at all uh by 2024
which is an absolute stunning thing
ahead of uh of countries around the
world i'm glad that she's uh praising me
for that the the cambo oil field as she
knows is is for study by an independent
regulator but what we what we have also
done and led the world in this mr
speaker is stopped the financing of
overseas hydrocarbons and that is a
fantastic thing which the whole world
followed dr andrew morris to speaker net
zero leveling up and building back
better can't happen unless we have a
massive increase in the supply of
critical tech minerals like silicon
copper and lithium but beijing controls
most of them
noting china's recent tech minerals
leverage on japan does he agree with me
that the success of our green industrial
revolution hinges on advancing our
indigenous silicon valley
and free of the eu what fiscal
incentives can he now provide to make it
happen at pace
minister i thank my my honourable friend
for that and uh as he knows there are
some uh very very interesting and
potentially very lucrative sources of uh
minerals such as lithium in this country
which uh whose uh exploration discovery
and reuse we are encouraging uh but
secondly on the on the tax point that he
rightly uh raises we're going to use
free ports to ensure that we uh support
the uh them as hubs for the processing
of those critical uh minerals here in
the uk
current thank you mr speaker in 2014 my
constituents three-year-old son freddie
hussey was killed by an unsafe trailer
every year 30 percent of people who do
the b plus e test fail it and now the
government is abolishing that test
unleashing thousands of untrained
untested
unsafe drivers onto our roads why is the
government breaking its promise to
grieving families to make towing and our
roads safer yeah prime minister i thank
her very much for raising this uh with
me and uh and i'm very sorry to hear
about the tragic circumstances of uh of
freddie's death and what we what we want
to do is to uh is to free up a b e
licensing uh time so we get more people
qualified as hgv drivers but that cannot
compromise road safety as she as she
rightly says
so we will we will review the
legislation and its consequences at
regular intervals
thank you speaker
on the 25th of december lincoln will be
hosting its world-famous christmas
market in the grounds of the historic
and it would be rivers for me not to
invite my honourable friend the prime
minister and and yourself speaker and
all other colleagues even the opposition
front bench to come and enjoy the
marvelous long weekend of
festive festivities however what is less
than marvelous to my constituents is the
leveling down of lincolnshire's highway
maintenance ground by 25
on 2019 to 2020 levels can my vulnerable
friend use his influence to cause the
treasury and dft to revisit this
unfortunate decision restoring this
grant back to 1920 levels is imperative
to the safety of my constituents whether
in vehicles cycling or walking as i
would hope my right or friend would
agree
yeah uh well i i thank you very much for
this question i'll do my uh my utmost uh
as i'm sure all other uh he's invited
everybody uh so
i'm sure
a lot of people are gonna be going to
lincoln uh i hope uh but i'm sure that
my old friend the secretary of state for
transport would have listened very
carefully uh to what he had to say
inexplicable mr speaker is how former
vaccine task force chair kate bingham
described his government's decision to
cancel its contract with
livingston-based vaccine developer val
neva a company the prime minister has
himself visited she also noted how
shortly val neva have been treated and
how damaging his government's decision
has been for uk life sciences exports
and for jobs in my livingston
constituency where the state-of-the-art
vaccine manufacturing plant now lies
unfinished there has been no apology to
the incorrect statements in the house so
can the prime minister please meet with
me and representatives from val neva and
will he tell me whether his government
has tabled any proposals to reach an
amicable resolution which was promised
at the dispatch box and if not when will
they do so the minister yes i i thank
you very much and i i was i was
personally very disappointed when we
couldn't get approval for the uh for the
valeneva vaccine in the way that uh that
we had hoped and i know how
disappointing uh that was to uh to to
colleagues in in scotland uh i will
certainly make sure that she gets the
the relevant meeting but what we are
doing is investing massively in this
country's vaccine capability across the
country so that we are prepared for the
next pandemic and i very much hope that
val never will be part of that nigel
bills
thank you
we know that serious side effects from
the covered vaccines are very rare but
for my constituent sarah kite that
wasn't the case and she suffered
a very serious reaction leaving her in
constant pain and losing most of her
eyesight and she now can't work the
prime minister successfully and quite
likely speed up all the vaccine
processes except one the vaccine damage
payment system can we now get on with
making those payments people who have
suffered these very very serious
reactions and get the financial support
they need
prime minister yes
uh i i thank him very much and uh i i
just want to to reassure him and
reassure him and you need to reassure
the house and the country that cases
such as the very sad one that he raises
are extremely extremely rare and we're
putting more uh more money in to gather
evidence for claims uh such as the one
that he describes but i want to repeat
uh perhaps the most important message i
can i could get across again today mr
speaker i want to repeat how vital uh
that vaccination program is how safe it
is and how important it is that
everybody who is eligible gets there
gets their booster when they're called
thank you mr speaker
the government's integrated review
concluded that the chinese state poses a
systemic challenge to our national
security and the prime minister has made
clear that when it comes to china we
must remain vigilant about our critical
national infrastructure can he therefore
confirm today unequivocally that plans
for china general nuclear to own and
operate its own plant in bradwell in
essex have been abandoned and explained
to the house precisely how and when his
government intends to remove cgn's
interest from the size we'll see nuclear
project here prime minister
i thank him very much for the invert for
his question a very important issue that
he that he raises and uh clearly one of
the
the consequences of our of our approach
on critical national infrastructure the
national security and investment bill uh
is that we don't uh want to see uh undue
influence
uh by uh
potentially uh uh adversarial uh
countries in our critical national
infrastructure and so that's why we've
taken the decisions that we that we have
and on bradwell on bradwell uh there
will be uh more more information
forthcoming but i want what i don't want
what i don't want to do mr speaker is
pitch fork away uh wantonly all chinese
investment in this country or minimize
the importance of this country of having
a having a a trading relationship with
with china daniel kurczynski
thank you very much mr speaker um the
prime minister will be very pleased that
shrewsbury conservatives are doing
everything possible to help neil shastri
hurst
the excellent candidate in north
shropshire
but he will also know that the number
one issue affecting syllopians at the
moment is the 312 million pounds that
we've secured for a modernization of our
amd services this has suffered terrible
delays over the last eight years leading
to a worsening of our amd
services for local patients will he do
everything possible to help us get this
finally across the line so that we can
provide safe amd services for all the
people of shropshire and mid wales prime
minister
i thank him very much and that's one of
the reasons why we're investing 36
billion pounds more in our nhs now to
help cope with the the backlog the extra
winter pressures particularly on a e uh
but it's also a reason why uh the
booster program is so vital because we
don't want those those beds filled with
covered patients and we don't want
delayed discharges either
thank you mr speaker so far has
government have found belgians for
nuclear but nothing for scottish carbon
capture cluster nothing for pump storage
hydro and now are at risk of failing the
tidal stream generation a technology
scotland's a world leader and now the
ask is for a 71 million pound ring fence
marine port and next month's energy
auction so prime minister's got a choice
provide this money and allow continued
scale up commercial success based on a
uk supply chain or see the manufacturing
jobs move abroad what's it going to be
well mr speaker i'm so glad you asked
that question uh because uh i can tell
him and i can tell her his right
honourable friend the the leaders of the
snp uh in westminster that we will be
including a a a support for a uh for
tidal stream
for title stream uh in the upcoming uh
to the value of 20 million pounds
come on
not to be sneezed at nothing not not to
be sneezed down mr speaker in the
upcoming contract for difference auction
i've met representatives of scottish
tidal power i think it's it's fantastic
original inventive what they're doing uh
we want to support it so david
mr speaker prime minister i've been out
campaigning with our excellent candidate
in bexie said cut louis france
for the by-election and responses on the
doorstep are very good
can
can my well the opposition know nothing
as usual
can my right on a friend confirm
that he will continue to implement our
2019 manifesto and implement policies to
ensure that we build up better for the
whole country including london because
this is what the electors and bexley
want
yes mr speaker i can and i have happy
memories over many years of campaigning
with uh my old friend in bexley uh and
seek up and i can tell him that we are
delivering on our agenda for the people
of
london putting 20 000 more police out on
the street and making sure that they get
to outer london boroughs as well and
making sure that londoners do not suffer
from the crazed outer london tax uh
we've seen motorists motorists penalized
by the labour mayor for driving into it
driving into their own city
thank you mr speaker the chairwell
ladder in kiddlington does incredible
work serving nearly 2 000 of my most
vulnerable constituents but at the
moment there simply isn't enough food to
go around and this is a national crisis
stock for charities like fair share is
down thirty percent in part due to the
same supply chain issues that are
affecting supermarkets so will the prime
minister help the terwaldo firstly by
restoring the funding to fair share but
also what more can he do to incentivize
businesses to give away surplus food
this winter so that no family need go
hungry this christmas
private stuff i want to thank her for
raising fair share and what they're
doing to uh to support uh people uh this
this winter and
indeed at all times but i would also say
that my experience of business is that
they do an amazing job of contributing
uh to this effort uh iceland is one of
the companies that that springs to mind
uh but to the on the on the uh on the
supply chains uh the uh we're we're
addressing it night and day and we are
seeing uh some of the some of the uh the
problems starting to ease they are they
are the result uh mr speaker of the uh
british and the world economy coming
back into life uh which quite frankly
would not have happened if we listened
to the general opposition
thank you mr speaker my rightful friend
the prime minister was bang on on monday
when he spoke about ending the
unfairness of our high energy intensive
industries paying more than they pay
overseas so we know he is a friend to
stealing skunk so will he continue to do
all that he can to ensure that my
world-class steel makers are on a fair
footing
prime minister yeah i thank him i thank
my honourable friend and everything she
does for for
for steele uh
and for scanthorpe and uh i i can tell
her that uh i i do believe that uh
british steel uh has suffered as a
result of decisions taken taken years
and years ago uh from uh from unfair
energy costs we need to fix it and this
government is getting on and making
another of the long-term changes where
we're instituting mr speaker we're
putting in the nuclear base load that
this country has long been deprived of
john speller thank you mr speaker prime
minister in a couple of weeks time i'll
be introducing a bill to ban the import
of hunting trophies not only does that
have widespread public support and
support from opposition parties but in
the past the principle has been
supported by conservative manifestos the
queen's speech and indeed by yourself so
prime minister on friday the 10th of
december will you tell your whips not to
block the bill but to let it go forward
so we can work together and end this
vile trade as soon as possible
[Applause]
the honourable general is completely
right and
that's why we're going to introduce
legislation uh this parliament to ban to
ban the import of hunting trophies and
delivering the change that we promised
and i hope that he will support it
mr speaker the prime minister cheered
all of my constituents up when he came
to southwest hertfordshire and said we
were going to have a new hospital
sadly prime minister even though the
money's there
the local management of our trust have
blocked it
they're going to refurbish watford and
not give us a brand new hospital on a
greenfield site which is what we want
prime minister will you meet me and some
of my constituents to unblock this and
tell the nhs they need to build a new
hospital for him or hempstead
prime minister uh i i'm grateful to my
friend i do remember the uh the issue
being raised with me when i was uh when
i was with him i would be very happy to
secure
a a meeting with uh my right friend the
secretary of state uh for health and and
i'm sure we'll be able to unblock things
one way or the other
thank you mr speaker uh scott's stood
slack jawed this week with astonishment
at the news that the prime minister has
abandoned his dup bridge to northern
ireland
perhaps he'll offer hot air balloons for
the crossing instead and inflate him
himself
broken bridge promises to scotland
broken real promises to northern england
with buyer's remorse consuming the tory
backbenchers who does he think will be
defenestrated first his hapless tory
leader in scotland or himself
prime minister
mr speaker i i just want to remind the
scottish nationalist party they are
there to represent the people of
scotland and to deliver better services
uh better transport better healthcare
better and and what we are deli what we
are delivering uh he talks about he
talks about transport mr speaker i'll
tell you what i said to the the to the
leader of the snp in in westminster what
we are delivering is the first
thoroughgoing review of union
connectivity so that we look properly at
all those roads the a75 the a 77 the a1
all those all those vital connections
for the people of scotland that have
been neglected by the snp that this
government is going to fix
final question
thank you mr speaker i'm absolutely
delighted with the half a billion pound
start for life funding that was
announced in the budget and my right
honourable friend knows from personal
experience how important those early
years are whether that's parenting
advice access to health care or age
appropriate theme parks
so does he agree that rolling out family
hugs to 75 local authority areas is a
great start but can he confirm that if
this is a successful program the
government's aim is to roll it out
across the whole country
the prime minister
i i thank her very much and she's
totally right in what she says about
start for life and i'm just seeing if my
uh my right honourable friend uh still
in a place where she's vanished but i
wanna i wanna thank uh uh my royal
friend the member of northampton because
she has a championed this for many many
years she is right uh mr speaker
investment in kids early years is
absolutely crucial that's why this
government has begun start for life and
yes if it works mr speaker
we will run it out across the country
we're not going to come to the urgent
questions for those who need to leave
please do so
too lively
no problem look after yourselves
thank you thank you prime minister
i'm always nice
we now come to the urgent question